BUT FIRST, THE LIBERALS FREAK
OUT AS TRUMP REACHES OUT.
THAT'S A FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
IT WAS AN AMAZING MOMENT IN THE
OVAL OFFICE TODAY WHEN POP
CULTURE ICON AND RAPPER
EXTRAORDINAIRE KANYE WEST MET
WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP BEFORE THE
CAMERA.
HE UNLEASHED A TEN MINUTE
MONOLOGUE WHERE HE TRIED TO
EXPLAIN HIS LOVE OF ALL THINGS
MEGA.
>> THEY TRY TO SCARE ME TO NOT
WEAR THIS HAT, MY OWN FRIENDS.
BUT THIS HAT, IT GIVES ME POWER
AND AWAY.
MY DAD AND MY MOM SEPARATED, SO
I DIDN'T HAVE A LOT OF MAIL
ENERGY IN MY HOME.
IT WAS SOMETHING ABOUT PUTTING
THIS HAT ON, IT MADE ME FEEL
LIKE SUPERMAN.
LIKE WHEN I NEED IT SATURDAY
LIVE TO IMPROVE ON OR THE
LIBERALS TO IMPROVE ON, WHEN HE
DON'T LOOK GOOD, WE DON'T LOOK
GOOD.
THIS IS OUR PRESIDENT.
STEEL AND SOMETIMES UNLIKELY
FIGURES EMERGE IN AMERICAN
HISTORY TO PLAY IMPORTANT ROLES.
ELIMINATING AT TIMES IMPORTANT
TRUTHS.
TODAY, KANYE WEST IN HIS OWN NET
CENTRIC WAY EXPOSING TOLERANCE
OF THE LEFT.
THEY ARE DENUNCIATIONS OF HIS
WHITE HOUSE APPEARANCE WERE
IMMEDIATE AND WITHERING.
>> WHEN IT COMES TO ISSUES OF
KANYE WEST BRINGING BLACK PEOPLE
TO PRESIDENT TRUMP, THAT'S A
MISNOMER.
>> IT DOESN'T SPEAK TO THE
DIVERSITY OR THE BROAD
EXPERIENCES OF 40 MILLION BLACK
PEOPLE.
>> THIS IS A REALITY TV SHOW WE
WERE WATCHING.
>> THAT WAS AN ASSAULT ON A
WHITE HOUSE.
>> AN ASSAULT ON OUR
WHITE HOUSE?
WELL KANYE DID USE SOME COARSE
LANGUAGE THAT HE SHOULDN'T HAVE
USED, AND HE WAS SPEAKING HIS
OWN TRUTHS.
BUT IF YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT
ASSAULTS OR IMPROPRIETIES IN THE
WHITE HOUSE, WHAT ABOUT THIS?
OR THIS?
KANYE WEST IS HARDLY A POLITICAL
PHILOSOPHER, AND I'VE ALWAYS
BELIEVED THAT ENTERTAINERS
SHOULD FIRST ENTERTAIN AND KEEP
THEIR POLITICS SEPARATE FROM
THEIR ART.
BUT I CANNOT REMEMBER ANY ARTIST
ON THE LEFT WHO WAS TREATED WITH
THE SAME VITRIOL AND HATRED AS
KANYE WEST HAS BEEN SUBJECTED TO
SINCE HE ANNOUNCED HIS SUPPORT
FOR THE PRESIDENT.
WHEN KATY PERRY OR MILEY CYRUS
WERE HEADLINING HILLARY CLINTON,
I DON'T REMEMBER ANYONE AT MSNBC
OR CNN CRITICIZING THEM FOR
LACKING POLICY EXPERIENCES.
WHEN HILLARY CLINTON SAT DOWN
WITH AND MARY JAY OBLIGED.
[SINGING]
♪♪ IT AIN'T NO SECRET, NO SECRET
MY FRIEND, YOU CAN GET KILLED
FOR LIVING IN YOUR AMERICAN
SKIN ♪♪
>> Laura: IS LIKE AN OLD
COFFEE COMMERCIAL FROM THE 70s
70s.
AND OBAMA WAS THE BIGGEST
CELEBRITY HOUND OF THEM ALL.
HERE IS THAT BARACK AND MICHELLE
SERENADING USHER IN THE
WHITE HOUSE BUT NO IMPROPRIETY
OR ASSAULT ON THE WHITE HOUSE
THEN.
WHAT ABOUT BEYONCE AND JAY-Z?
THEY WERE IN THE WHITE HOUSE
MORE FREQUENTLY THAN THE
SECRET SERVICE AND THAT WAS ALL
PERFECTLY ACCEPTABLE.
NO POLICY CONCERNS THEN.
BUT WHEN IT WAS ANNOUNCED TWO
DAYS BACK THAT KANYE WOULD BE
HOLDING A MEETING AT THE
WHITE HOUSE WITH TRUMP, ALL HECK
BROKE LOOSE.
>> HE IS THE TOKEN OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
>> KANYE IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
THEY DON'T READ.
>> KANYE IS BEING SUBJECTED TO
THE ATTACKS THAT AWAKEN ANY
BLACK CONSERVATIVE WHO DARES TO
BREAK RANKS WITH THE DEMOCRATIC
MONOLITH.
LET'S KIND OF TREAT THESE
ENTERTAINERS LIKE PAWNS WHO ARE
NOT ALLOWED TO DEVIATE FROM THE
LEFTIST GROUPS AT ALL.
GOD PROTECTS ANY HISPANIC, OR
BLACK WHO BREAKS RANKS AND GOES
THEIR OWN WAY POLITICALLY.
REMEMBER THE SCORN THAT SINGER
HARRY BELAFONTE HEAPED ON
CONDOLEEZZA RICE AND COLIN
POWELL FOR WORKING FOR
GEORGE BUSH?
>> THEY BELIEVE SHE DOES, AND MY
REFERENCE TO THEM MEANT THAT
THEY WERE NOT THE MASTERS OF
THEIR OWN DESTINY ALTHOUGH THEY
HAD THE CHOICE TO BE.
>> HOUSE SLAVES, THAT'S REALLY
NICE.
THE REAGAN ADMINISTRATION ARGUED
THAT BLACK SHOULD CAST OFF
CONSERVATIVISM FOR CONSERVATIVE
SOLUTIONS AND SUMMED UP HOW THE
G.O.P. HAD LOST SO MUCH GROUND.
SAYING DEMOCRATS SMUGLY ASSUME
BLACKS ARE MONOLITHIC AND WILL
BY FORCE OF CIRCUMSTANCES ALWAYS
HUDDLE TO THE LEFT OF THE
POLITICAL SPECTRUM.
THE POLITICAL RIGHT WATCHES THIS
HERD MENTALITY AND ACTION AND,
WISTFULLY SHRUGS AT THE
SEEMINGLY UNBREAKABLE HOLD OF
THE LIBERAL LEFT OF BLACK
AMERICANS.
THAT OFFICIAL'S NAME WAS
CLARENCE THOMAS, THEN CHAIR OF
THE EQUAL OPPORTUNITY
COMMISSION.
INDIVIDUALS SUCH AS THE
BRILLIANT CONSERVATIVE ECONOMIST
TOM SOUL WERE CREATED JUST
BECAUSE AS THOMAS NOTED, THEY
REFUSED TO GIVE INTO THE OCCULT
MENTALITY AND CHILDLESS
OBEDIENCE THAT HYPNOTIZED BLACK
AMERICANS INTO MINDLESS
POLITICAL TRANCE.
THIS IS JUSTICE THOMAS IN 2007.
>> WE ARE HERE NOT TO BE
PROSELYTIZED BUT TO THINK FOR
OURSELVES.
AND ISN'T THAT ONE OF THE
REASONS WE LOVE OUR FREE
SOCIETY, WE GET TO THINK FOR
OURSELVES AND MAKE OUR DECISIONS
BASED ON CERTAIN PRINCIPLES,
AND, TO MAKE IT POSSIBLE FOR
OTHERS TO DO THE SAME?
BE ONE ABSOLUTELY.
NOW UNLESS HE IS DOING A GIANT
PLUNKING OF AMERICA, HE HAS GUTS
AND GUSTO.
JUST BECAUSE HE DARES TO THINK
FOR HIMSELF, THINK DIFFERENTLY,
AND HIS OUTSPOKEN OVER-THE-TOP
MANNER, HE IS -- JOURNALISM AND
OF COURSE THE ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY.
HE REPRESENTS A DANGER TO THE
LEFT BECAUSE OF HIS HUGE
CULTURAL INFLUENCE.
IN MOMENTS LIKE THIS, THEY ARE
ABSOLUTELY INTOLERABLE.
>> I DON'T WANT TO PUT YOU IN
THAT SPOT.
>> I LOVE THIS GUY RIGHT HERE.
I LOVE THIS GUY RIGHT HERE.
>> THE MONOPOLY ON BLACK VOTERS
IS IN JEOPARDY.
THERE ARE MORE REASONS FOR THE
LIBERALS TO BE CONCERNED.
PRESIDENT TRUMP NOW HAS A 36
APPROVAL RATING.
SOME ATTRIBUTED THE RISE TO
SUPPORT FROM CONNIE WEST AND OF
COURSE AT HISTORIC LOW
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE IN THE BLACK
COMMUNITY.
WHATEVER THE CAUSE, WHATEVER THE
REASON, THE SHIFTING SUPPORT
AMONG AFRICAN-AMERICANS IS VERY,
VERY SIGNIFICANT.
DEMOCRATS CANNOT WIN A NATIONAL
ELECTION WITHOUT THEIR HUGE
SWATH OF BLACK VOTERS, AND
PERHAPS KANYE IS GIVING THEM A
REASON TO LOOK ELSEWHERE FOR
POLITICAL ANSWERS.
SO NEXT TIME YOU HEAR LIBERAL
PUNDITS WRITING HIM OFF AS A
CRAZY SLAVE DENYING LUNATIC,
REMEMBER, IT'S ALL ABOUT THE
NUMBERS.
THEY HAVE TO SMEAR WEST FOR FEAR